(music)
Eddie Glaude:
We have reveled in the sheer joy of coming back,
of reconnecting with old friends who have helped shape us,
Eddie Glaude:
and of glimpsing, if for just a moment,
what the future might hold for old Nassau --
Eddie Glaude:
a future that does not simply include us,
but a future impossible to imagine without us.
(music, conversations)
Photographer:
Okay, here we go. Last shot. Thanks for your patience. Here we go. Look right over here. Umbrellas down.
Group:
Cheese.
Photographer:
Have a great reunion! (crowd cheers)
(music)
Shirley M. Tilghman:
When I think about Princeton in the future,
and think about the ideal of what Princeton would look like
Shirley M. Tilghman:
if we put a map of the world up, my picture is there would be
Princeton right in the middle of the map,
Shirley M. Tilghman:
and there would be lines going in and out of Princeton,
literally to every other part of the world that reflects what the
Shirley M. Tilghman:
faculty have called networks and flows.
We want to be the center of the universe.
(laughter, applause)
(music)
Cornel West:
You all remember Donny Hathaway and Roberta Flack from 1974?
Where is... where is the love?
Cornel West:
You see in the end, it's all about the love.
All the rest is sounding brass and tinkling cymbal.
Cornel West:
If you love wisdom, you ought to be a philosopher.
If you love justice, you ought to be a politician or
Cornel West:
a judge or a good citizen.
If you love the life of the mind, come to Princeton.
Cornel West:
If you love the world of ideas, come to Princeton.
If you love yourself, keep working on it,
Cornel West:
though you'll find out you can't really love yourself unless you love somebody else.
(music)
Robert Durkee:
I do hope that one of the messages you take from this
conference is that Princeton continues to change and progress
Robert Durkee:
has been made. Princeton surely has become a
more diverse and welcoming place, and it has staked out a
Robert Durkee:
leadership position in placing an understanding of race and the
African American experience among its highest priorities.
(music)
(cheers, applause)